that is brilliant
face tired but the message still tough
this former comic actor cast in a new
role of wartime commander in chief
speaking on the eve of the war one
minister said he'd rise to the challenge
and his past media career would help
he's already a president for around
three years
and
he learned a lot
and especially in the crisis uh people
who worked in our business
used to be under the pressure for a
whole period of time so probably
even better under the pressure than in
normal life
that pressure exploded hours later when
the first missiles struck
seemingly from his phone the moment the
president announced russia had invaded
hard to believe this was him just a few
years ago playing the role of a
politician who becomes a leader
now handling the greatest security
crisis in europe for real
on the deserted streets of kiev there's
new support for their tv star turned
statesman
i think our president became a real
leader since the last 48 hours because
before i was not quite happy about him
but now he is
his attitude
much
more appropriate and he is example of
courage to our people yeah
the president knows regime change is
vladimir putin's ultimate goal but if
that threat scares him he's not letting
it show
in fact when the us offered to evacuate
him from the capital for his own safety
he apparently responded i need
ammunition not a ride
it's a stark change from almost up until
the bomb started dropping when he'd
played down the threat to the bemusement
of western allies
[Applause]
here on a recent holiday as russian
troops massed at the border
[Applause]
yet when that optimism was shattered the
president didn't shy away
[Music]
instead playing to his strengths using
social media posts to rally his people
a very different approach from his arch
enemy who's distant from even his
closest ministers
the smears held at zelensky all the more
insulting given he's jewish
no hostages here just a president
holding his nerve debrahing sky news
keeve